nous sommes le jeudi 17 novembre 2016
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les inviter celles et ceux qui font
l'actualité dans le département voici le
sommaire marie-christine le tarnec dans
le fauteuil de maire à guyancourt élu en
début de semaine elle succède à françois
de ligne est en poste depuis 2002 son
projet elle nous emporte dans un instant
le département des yvelines poursuit sa
politique d'insertion et met l'accent
sur la formation les précisions de
katrina renaud vice-présidente en charge
de ces questions et puis rencontre avec
renan rivière metteurs en scènes de
faust présenté au théâtre montansier à
versailles vendredi soir vous allez
redécouvrir l'un des couples les plus
mythiques de la littérature bleus née
sous la plume de goethe politique donc
avec une nouvelle ère qui débute
guyancourt françois de ligne est maire
depuis 2002 vient de céder sa place à
marie christine le tarnec à 60 ans
l'ancienne première adjointe chargée de
l'éducation de la jeunesse des finances
va donc prendre en main est les rênes de
la commune
nicolas kirillovitch est allé la
rencontrer avec et lucile decker pour
les images mari si le tarnec est
désormais là nouveau maire la nouvelle
maire de guyancourt depuis ce mardi avec
15 novembre elle a été élue avec 26 voix
pour 4 blanc et 2 contres madame le
tarnec madame la maire la nouvelle maire
de guyancourt dites nous quel est votre
sentiment quel sentiment vous anime ce
soir j'imagine lui avoir de la fierté de
l'émotion alors beaucoup d'émotion aussi
puisque je me retrouve devant beaucoup
d'habitants et qu'ils étaient
effectivement présents pour cette
élection
et puis une responsabilité je mesure la
responsabilité qui est la mienne
maintenant d'être maire de guyancourt et
j'aurai à coeur effectivement
de répondre à la demande des clients
courtois et de continuer projet de vie
pour lequel nous ont élus justement
comment vous envisagez ces quatre
nouvelles années pour vous en tant qu'
en tant que maire ça a été beaucoup
répété dans la soirée le mot continuité
c'est celui ci qu'il faut retenir en
priorité
alors oui puisque j'ai été élu sur une
liste depuis 2014 donc maintenant je
suis maire effectivement au milieu du
mandat mais j'ai participé à la liste de
françois de ligne et on a été élu pour
un mandat effectivement de 6 ans avec un
projet de ville et je vais respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris devant les
gluants pour toi et on va les tenir
quel va être le rôle selon vous enfin
pour vous de françois de ligne est
désormais qui reste au sein du conseil
municipal est ce que vous allez vous
appuyez sur ses conseils son expérience
dans un premier temps comment vous
envisagez votre nouvelle relation avec
lui
alors qu'on soit humilié a toujours dit
qu'ils feraient la totalité du mandat
donc ils respectent effectivement ce
qu'il a dit il sera conseiller municipal
je vais profiter et l'ensemble de l'eee
qui vont profiter de son expérience de
ses compétences sur de nombreux sujets
et on est ravi effectivement qu'il reste
avec nous jusqu'à la fin du mandat comme
il l'avait elle annoncé quels sont les
grands dossiers qui vous attendent là
tout de suite prochainement pour pour
guyancourt sur quoi vous allez plancher
très rapidement alors on a des
continuités il ya le mal des sceaux sur
lequel on va effectivement poursuivre le
travail il ya l'arrivée de la ligne 18
avec elle
l'aménagement du terrain thales on a
beaucoup de l'entrée du droit aussi avec
la maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
des logements qui arrive on a beaucoup
d'engagement qui ont été pris qui
commence effectivement à se mettre en
place soit se terminer comme châteauneuf
où la clinique de soins de suite va
ouvrir ses portes au mois de janvier
et on est un projet de résidence à terme
déjà un soleil qui verra le jour d'ici
quelques quelques mois un dernier mot
sur vos futures relations avec
l'opposition municipale et celle du coup
elle a été parfois c'était rare mais
parfois compliquées avec monsieur de
ligne et on part sur de nouvelles bases
avec avec vous en tant que mère je ne
sais pas ça dépendra beaucoup aussi de
leur comportement
je les dis dans mon discours le conseil
municipal c'était un endroit
on peut débattre mais il faut être
respectueux des idées des personnes et
c'est ce que j'attends de l'opposition
madame le maire merci beaucoup merci
social le conseil départemental des
yvelines et son agence d'insertion
activités ont embauché des bénéficiaires
du rsa dans les différents collèges je
vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
catherine arenou c'est la
vice-présidente déléguée à l'insertion
la politique de la ville au sein de ce
conseil départemental des yvelines
c'est un dispositif c'est ça qui a été
pensée en ordre au printemps 2016 mais
en place jeudi quatre mois de mise en
place pour trouver avec pôle emploi les
profils pour prendre en charge
parce que l'état et le département paye
le contrat aidé mais pôle emploi assure
la formation de ses agents ce que c'est
il était aussi question à la fois de
trous de leur trouver un emploi mais de
les mettre dans un perspective à la fois
de formation pour une employabilité pour
l'avenir alors l'idée ce n'est pas de
transformer tous les bénéficiaires du
rsa en futurs agents de la fonction
publique
l'idée c'est de les mettre dans un
parcours d'employabilité
l'idée c'est de travailler au plus près
à votre pôle emploi pour les pour les
compétences de départ et la capacité
deux formations pour qu'ils aient un
avenir professionnel de dans ou en
dehors de la collectivité locale
moi ce que j'espère c'est que ce soit en
dehors de la collective dic locale
des entreprises marchandes il va falloir
en plus très régulièrement renouvelés
pour qu'on puisse toucher le plus grand
nombre de bénéficiaires du rsa possible
à partir du moment où le département
s'est donné des moyens par la création
de ce gip activity de travailler sur
l'insertion des publics les plus
éloignés de l'emploi d'abord des
bénéficiaires du rsa de façon à ce qu'il
retrouve une capacité d'emploi on peut
pas imaginer que notre première
philosophie soit l'économie
non mais il est vrai quand même qu'un
département qui dont le niveau de
financement de crs ça augmente toujours
doit se poser des vraies questions pour
l'avenir de ses habitants l'avenir de
ses habitants c'est à chaque fois que
c'est possible mettre en insertion ça il
a des capacités à faire nous nous sommes
donné les moyens
le gip activity actuellement regroupe un
sabre coppock bien évidemment que le
département
les tailles présents autour de lui la
plus pôle emploi est présent quelle
allocation familiale et présente
maintenant les communautés la commune
grosse communauté urbaine du département
est présent la région est présente à
dire qu'on est en fait dans cette
logique de formation
et puis de remettre à l'emploi les
habitants de notre territoire les plus
éloignés de l'emploi
partant de l'état en passant par la
région et de son plan de 60000 formation
dont bénéficient d'ailleurs à ce
dispositif la collectivité
départementale ou l'émanation la
politique dictée départementale qui est
activity ainsi qu'une collectivité plus
réduite qui sont ces communautés
d'agglomération de ces communautés
urbaines
oui parce qu'il ya la fois une
connaissance précise des publics qui
sont en difficulté public du bol devenir
une connaissance précise des nouveaux
métiers qui auront besoin des métiers en
tension qui auront besoin d'agents
formés et c'est aussi ça il faut aussi
travailler un petit peu en amont
et puis c'est les pouvoirs publics les
plus élevés c'est à dire les tailles la
région qui sont en capacité de former et
de donner des moyens financiers
oui moi je crois à ces quatre as et au
moins quatre niveaux pour réfléchir les
la politique d'insertion sur nos
territoires culture à présent du 21 au
23 novembre le collectif voit des plumes
investi la scène du théâtre montansier à
versailles la troupe propose une
création faust inspiré du célèbre
ouvrage éponyme de l'auteur allemand
goethe
l'oeuvre raconte l'histoire d'un savant
vendant son âme
au diable pour rester avec sa dulcinée
mélanie poker a rencontré ronan rivières
c'est le metteur en scène on en rivière
bonjour donc vous présenter faust au
théâtre montansier faust est un
classique
pourquoi vous le proposer aux
spectateurs et bien si je monte des
spectacles c'est toujours par coups de
coeur littéraires et vous l'avait bien
dit c'est un classique c'est pas pour
rien c'est parce que c'est une
magistrale qui a lancé une déferlante
littéraire dans la dans le fantastique
et avec une des nouveautés dans
l'écriture qui sont des ruptures
temporelle des dé plusieurs espaces
plusieurs lieux
une multitude de personnages qui crée
une histoire très vivante et un style
assez nouveau houleux il n'y a pas un
genre déterminé c'est ni tout à fait
comique ni tout à fait tragique
bien sûr ça se termine mal mais il ya le
diable qui est là qui est une figure
quand même de bouffons qui amène un
personnage comique et qu'est ce qui vous
attire et principalement vous parlez la
tragédie l'écriture de goethe
les personnages en eux mêmes alors plus
que l'écriture de goetz et le couple
goethe nerval qui me plaît en général
qui est le traducteur de la pièce
l'équipe qui est inquiet pas n'importe
quel traducteur c'est celle que tu étais
très carré il a la très structuré un
grand homme politique qui a structuré la
langue allemande avec ses oeuvres et qui
a fait des oeuvres tout est totalement
nouvelle mais mais mais avec une quand
même une grande réflexion et nerval y
ajoute un souffle romantique français
puisque lui était le contraire de goethe
à c'est un grand poète romantique et
totalement tourmenté complètement fou on
peut le dire et comme vous avez demandé
à vos acteurs de travailler il y adeux
du drame il ya des tragédies comment ça
se joue alors surtout de ne pas penser à
ce drame tragédie ou comédie à vivre sur
l'instant les choses tout en faisant
entendre le texte se nécessite une
technique mais dans toujours dans
l'optique d'un théâtre populaire on est
à mi chemin entre le naturel et le style
donc on
on joue avec tout notre sincérité mais
on n'est pas naturaliste dans le sens où
on n'est pas à la télévision donc il
faut faire passer on élargit et on vit
les choses comme si tout était assez
exceptionnel merci on est en finale et
donc chose faite jusqu'au 23 novembre
avant de refermer cette édition du 7 8
les invités retour sur ce colloque
organisé autour du burn out à versailles
un colloque organisé par le syndicat cfe
cgt cgc pardon c'était ce jeudi 17
novembre et parmi les différents
intervenants des responsables politiques
dont le député socialistes candidats à
la primaire de gauche benoît hamon
porteur d'un projet de loi concernant le
burn out cette maladie professionnelle
d'épuisement qui pour l'instant n'est
reconnue que partiellement est également
présent pour le parti chrétien démocrate
jean frédéric poisson député est lui
aussi des yvelines est candidat à la
primaire de la droite écoutez les c'est
une proposition de loi qui veut
faciliter la reconnaissance du burn out
en pathologie psychique liée au travail
comme maladie professionnelle quand
votre dépression est directement
imputable au travail
elle a été déposée en février n'a pas
été inscrite à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale faute en théorie
de places en réalité parce que du côté
du
ministère du travail de van hamel
conneries il n'y a pas de volonté
d'avancer sur ce sujet le burn out est
encore souvent porté comme une espèce de
maladie un peu honteuse par ceux qui en
souffrent c'est une malade pathologique
est très peu connue des organisations
l'après la prévienne très mal une fois
qu'elles n'ont identifié la traite mal
parce que il ya une forme de mes
connaissances et d'absence de comment
dire de culture partagée sur sur cette
réalité
voilà pour les réactions de ces deux
députés à la fois de la gauche et de la
droite c'est la fin du set 8 invités
pour ce soir prochain rendez-vous est
lundi 18h45 d'ici là n'oubliez pas
nourri play sur notre site internet les
programmes se poursuivent sur tv fils